[Music]
we are now entering a new era where it
is possible to live younger longer all
while achieving the Financial Freedom of
our dreams powering this movement are
Legions of ambitious self-starters who
believe in doing well and doing good at
the same time this new Lifestyle System
may change everything about how we
engage in our health and prosperity but
it all started simply with an
inquisitive young man living on a farm
Dr Joel Wallock was born into Farm
living in rural Missouri where he tended
to vegetable crops and livestock with
equal care as he worked on his high
school studies and on becoming an eagle
scout Dr Wall gravitated towards animal
science plant science soil science and
veterinary medicine to learn more Dr
wallik got a summer job at the St Louis
Zoo where he had the privilege of caring
for EXO itic animals alongside Marlon
Perkins of Mutual of Omaha's Wild
Kingdom Fame inspired by Mr Perkins Dr
wallik found his mission early in life
to protect the welfare of animals plants
and the Earth itself he wanted all
living things to thrive and prosper back
on the Family Farm Dr wallik had an
epiphany that would Advance his new
mission for decades to come he realized
that livestock received better nut
nutrition than humans Dr wallik observed
that nutrient D Alfalfa pellets fed to
livestock were a costeffective gold
standard practice for preventing
infertility birth defects heart disease
arthritis and other degenerative
diseases but he wondered why is it
common practice for livestock to get
this nutrition but not humans as Dr
wallik went to the University of
Missouri to study Agriculture and
veterinary medicine medicine he was
determined to solve this nutritional
mystery in organic chemistry class Dr
wallik had another breakr when he
learned that minerals are needed for
hundreds of life sustaining reactions in
the body with his agricultural
background Dr wallik also knew that
these same minerals are often lacking in
the soil and in our diet Dr wallik knew
he was on to something significant after
receiving his Bachelor of Science and
agriculture in 19 62 and is doctored in
veterinary medicine in
1964 he began chasing the answers that
he knew would bring vibrant health and
wellness to all living creatures on
Earth he studied nutritional deficiency
diseases he began working as a
Veterinary pathology assistant
conducting up to 25 animal autopsies
daily he investigated the mineral intake
of the world's longest living cultures
he traveled to Africa to treat and save
exotic animals and endangered species in
1966 he was invited by Marlin Perkins to
participate in a 7.5 million National
Institutes of Health study on ecology
environment pollution and plant and
animal health the massive study became
Dr Wall's Focus for the next 12 years
over time Dr wallik performed thousands
of animal autopsies across 454 species
including 3,000 humans
his work was included in 70
peer-reviewed Journal articles and 15
textbook
chapters Dr wallik also began working on
his own textbook the diseases of exotic
animals the medical and surgical
management which is now recommended by
the Smithsonian Institute as a
foundation text for all
zoos Dr Wall's discoveries from this
prolific time are still used today to
reduce degenerative disease improve
fertility and extend longevity for
exotic animals and livestock but most
significantly after thousands of animal
and human autopsies Dr wallik gained
unprecedented Insight on the inner
workings of the Earth's inhabitants what
he discovered was a near Universal Trend
across species minerals were the
currency of life itself soon after this
Revelation Dr wallik identified the
first non-human case of cystic fibrosis
in a reesus monkey he named selenium
deficiency as the cause challenging the
established belief that the disease was
genetic in nature Dr Wall's findings
were met with resistance as the NIH and
media alike tried to silence his
Discovery and discredit his
qualifications knowing that his
discoveries could help millions of
people if he had additional
qualifications at age 40 Dr wallik
decided to become a naturopathic doctor
after receiving his ND Dr wallik started
a practice and began adapting his
Veterinary nutritional formulas for
human use these formulations such as his
liquid mineral ttty worked so well that
his patients told everyone they knew
soon his Clinic was seeing 50 people
daily with his Clinic's capacity maxed
out Dr wallik realized he needed a
better system that would enable him to
help more people information was the
answer by teaching others how to achieve
and share vibrant Health he could remove
all limitations and help millions of
people Dr wallet created an educational
Health seminar called Dead Doctors Don't
Lie the tape of his seminars resonated
so powerfully with Americans that it
sold over 150 million copies without the
benefit of social
media with Dead Doctors Don't Lie Dr
wallik finally had a way to go directly
to the public with his own information
on nutrition information he knew could
dramatically improve their health but Dr
Wall's next breakthrough was the real
GameChanger as his discoveries improved
livestock health and saved exotic
animals around the world Dr wallik
fulfilled part of his life's Mission but
it was just the beginning he knew his
Animal Health breakthroughs had the
potential to enhance human health too
with Dead Doctors Don't Lie Dr Joel
Wallock inspired millions of people to
take control of their health but he
wanted to do more he wanted to bring
people happiness Quality of Life
Financial Freedom and the best nutrition
in the world if he could pull these
pieces together in one place Dr wallik
knew he could realize his childhood
dream of helping others to thrive and
prosper just as he was seeking A Better
Way Dr wck was introduced to direct
sales in direct sales he saw the perfect
vehicle for helping people achieve the
vibrant health and financial stability
they wanted in return they would tell
others about their success backed by an
army of motivated Health Crusaders he
could now reach Millions with both
Health knowledge and the quality
nutrition that could change their lives
true to form he began methodically
dissecting the direct selling concept to
see how he could do it better than it
had ever been done before Dr wallick's
interest in direct sales culminated in
his launch of youngevity he built his
new direct sales brand on a commitment
to providing his distributors with the
finest products best support and fastest
payouts without interfering in their
everyday activities it all started with
physical health by supplying premium
nutritional formulations that were great
tasting easy to absorb and highly
bioavailable he could reverse
nutritional deficiencies he knew from
experience that his plant dered
colloidal mineral supplements delivered
Wellness benefits that were so powerful
people could feel them across all
aspects of their lives he also had
successful supplements from his Clinic
days that would Blossom on a bigger
stage Dr Wallock streamlined his 90
essential nutrients message into 90 for
life and presented his most important
supplement in a healthy body pack
youngevity now had its core Foundation
products in place as he pioneered new
youngevity supplements including
cuttingedge liquid and neutr Crystal
delivery forms he Unleashed even more
dramatic results people felt a
difference when they took them they
wanted to buy more because each new
youngevity product made them feel better
than before with youngevity supplements
results were now the rule not the
exception when people people felt better
physically happiness followed their
mental emotional and social health
flourished people were empowered by
their own Wellness which in turn
inspired others they felt so healthy
taking youngevity formulas that they
shared them with everyone they knew
through youngevity's direct selling
model Dr Waller could now reward these
people for their goodwi the more Health
that youngevity Distributors generated
the greater their financial rewards
would be and the more lives they could
change for the better the company
quickly outgrew its humble beginnings
but with little office space available
in Southern California leadership faced
a tough decision leaving the area would
mean losing the staff the founders led
by Dr wallik decided to keep the team
together stay local and build a
state-of-the-art headquarters with
nearly 60,000 Square ft of Class A
warehousing distribution and office
space to grow into youngevity was poised
for dramatic growth thousands of people
flocked to youngevity they wanted to
distribute the products that had
enhanced their lives the growing
distributor base included people from
all walks of life young and old rich and
poor all were United by a genuine desire
to help others his message spread
organically and quickly wherever
youngevity went health and prosperity
followed Zen how information transformed
health and affected positive change Dr
wallik developed a new goal to challenge
petition and at times defend the FDA to
enable qualified Health claims for
nutritional supplements in challenging
the FDA Dr wallik helped change the face
of healthc care in America securing the
ability to deliver truthful health
information to the public among his most
significant victories was a qualified
Health claim that the mineral SEL iium
May reduce the risk of certain cancers
Dr gearhard schraer head of the UCSD
chemistry Department founder of the
biological Trace element journal and one
of the official nominators for
candidates for the Nobel Prize in
medicine was the lead scientific Council
for this petition working alongside Dr
wallik to convince the FDA to allow this
claim youngevity became the first and
only direct sales company to ever
successfully petition in the FDA to make
qualified Health claims this reinforced
youngevity's reputation as being a
different type of direct sales company
one where creating Health was the top
priority achieved by any means necessary
today under youngevity physical
emotional and Financial Health are now
one with residual income earned from
spreading health and doing good in the
world youngevity Distributors have an
opportunity to design their own
lifestyle for many this means spending
more time with their families pursuing
their passions and doing what they love
all in great health while promoting
Health in others from day one youngevity
has redefined what a direct marketing
brand can achieve youngevity's best may
be yet to come it was designed to be a
legacy company that will continue
growing for
Generations youngevity is a company of
innovation like global leaders Amazon
apple and Netflix youngevity is
preparing to make several evolutionary
leaps that will drive its success for
decades to come youngevity has expanded
Beyond nutritional supplements and will
continue to do so in the future
youngevity will offer products that are
wholesome and good for the body and for
the soul if a product can contribute to
a customer's quality of life in any way
than it fits the new youngevity model
youngevity will continue developing
Innovative supplements to support
vibrant physical health however
youngevity's holistic view means a
greater diversity of new products will
now support emotional health Mental
Health and Social Health as well
youngevity's diverse product offerings
will build greater stability for the
brand in the future new offerings will
also enable youngevity to enhance lives
in new ways helping people feel good
look great and enjoy fulfillment every
day with greater variety youngevity will
give their valued customers more product
to fall in love with and more reasons to
reorder on a regular basis although
youngevity is branching out into new
areas the ultimate message Remains the
Same 90 for life and the Healthy Start
pack creating a foundation of physical
wellness that supports a healthier
happier and more prosperous life new
technologies are poised to play a
significant role in youngevity's future
growth youngevity will leverage the
latest social media video and digital
mediums to more effectively share Dr
Wall's original message of Nutritional
Health with these new social media tools
youngevity will connect to demographics
they could have never reached in the
past evolving technologies will bring
exciting new possibilities for
youngevity Distributors as well
even today thanks to smartphones and
tablets youngevity Distributors can hold
their very own international business in
the palm of their hand with the
flexibility this technology offers
youngevity Distributors will have the
opportunity to achieve the Leisure
Lifestyle of their dreams defined by
Mobility Freedom and
prosperity the ability to travel may be
especially helpful where youngevity is
headed youngevity will be expanding
internationally in coming years to
deliver Dr Wall's message to those who
need it most youngevity plans to bring
education and opportunity to an entirely
new Global audience helping them to take
charge of their health and their lives
at home and abroad youngevity plans to
continue acquiring new product lines and
with them quality people who share their
mission of helping
others young jevity is investing in a
own future by rewarding its people with
industry leading incentives youngevity's
silver Mercedes Club encourages
Distributors to help even more people as
does youngevity's millionaires Club
everyone deserves to experience the good
in life and youngevity brings hope that
everyone
can while the financial opportunity may
be great the checks issued are always a
reflection of gratitude from the people
that youngevity has helped that group is
getting bigger and bigger every
day today youngevity Veterans vast
numbers can be seen spilling out over
the stage at distributor
events it's all a culmination of the
same culture that Dr Wallock started 60
years ago as a young Eagle Scout who was
determined to help animals and plants
Thrive it's a culture of caring about
other people having a strong work ethic
and wanting to give back to society when
you're surrounded by good people who are
doing good life is just
better and so youngevity's future
success will not be measured by how many
products are sold but by how many lives
the brand helps to change for the
better by continuing to Pioneer products
and opportunities that unlock a healthy
body heart and wallet Young vity will
continue enabling generations of people
around the world to live younger
[Music]
longer